>>Male Presenter: We're delighted to have
Dr. David Agus joining us today.
He's a professor of medicine and engineering
at USC, and heads up the Westside Cancer Center
and the Center for Applied Molecular Medicine
there at USC.
He clearly excels in business as much as he
does in academics.
He's the cofounder of two personalized medicine
companies.
One is Navigenics and the other is Applied
Proteomics.
His recently published book, The End of Illness,
calls for a shift in the fundamental ways
in which we think about the actions of health
and illness, including a view of the body
as a complex system rather than a series of
simple causal chains.
He balances this philosophical approach with
a very practical one, laying out recommended
annual health checkpoints, lab results that
you should have done regularly, and why you
should not sit down all day at your job.
His book is really, for me, was all about
prevention and how to keep yourself healthy,
which is an area that both Google and Googlers
need to own as we grow older.
If all of that somehow left you in doubt about
his brilliance, Dr. Agus also has achieved
a degree of celebrity stardom.
He was on the Daily Show a few weeks ago with
Jon Stewart.
I guess what we're really all wondering is
what Jon Stewart says to his guests as he
leans over the desk as the camera pans out.
With that, I welcome Dr. David Agus.
[applause]
>>David Agus: Thank you.
It's funny, Jon Stewart-- Before the show,
I went up to him and I said, "I'm scared to
death.
I'm a cancer doc.
I do all this media, but being live with a
comic scares me a little."
And he said, "Listen, I'll give you a hint.
Most people at the end of the show stand up
and leave, but there's 30 seconds when the
credits roll.
You lean forward and talk to me.
People will think we're friends, and it will
work."
[laughter] Then I lean forward at the end
and he goes, "The deal was for me to have
told you this, is now you have to be my doctor."
[laughter]
It's a pleasure to be here.
Thank you.
The End of Illness is a declaratory, aggressive
title.
I submitted it to the publisher about 8, 9
months ago.
It was called, at the time, What Is Health?,
as an homage to Schrödinger's What Is Life?
book from the 1940s.
I had a call from the publisher saying, "Agus,
Steve Jobs just called and changed the title
of your book."
I'm like, "He did?"
And they're like, "He changed it to The End
of Illness."
I called Steve, and I said, "Steve, I love
the title, but why didn't you tell me or discuss
it with me?"
He goes, "Agus, it's not your job.
It's theirs."
I was like, "Okay."
I thought about it, and it is obviously and
aggressive title.
But it's something I believe in.
I truly believe we can delay illness to the
ninth or tenth decade.
If you look in the United States, 1956 was
the last year you can die of old age on a
death certificate.
Since then, we've had to have a cause, whether
it be diabetes or lung cancer or prostate
cancer.
You name it, there had to be a cause.
But I want to go back to the era of dying
of old age.
The paradox is in that if we delay illness
to the ninth or tenth decade, healthcare costs
will come down dramatically.
If you get ill in your 80s and 90s or 100s,
actually, you don't go to an intensive care
unit.
You don't go on a ventilator.
We treat you with dignity instead of trying
to prolong things.
Remember, over 60% of healthcare costs in
the United States right now are the last two
years of life.
We spend almost nothing from age 15 to age
55.
Obviously, part of the premise that I want
to push to you is we've got to shift that
because we have to prevent illness.
We are the number 1 spender in the world on
healthcare, and we're ranked 32nd.
Washington has ex bandwidth for health, and
most of it, if not all of it, is spent on
healthcare finance.
None of it's spent on health.
What I'm going to present you today is a new
way of looking at health and really focusing
on what I think we need to do as changes.
The book came out 3, 4 weeks ago.
What's amazing is I've already had about 6,
now, video conferences with member of the
Chinese government.
They're going to enact parts of the book as
law this summer.
Whereas the US government, it will take a
decade of debate before they even bring it
up to talk about it publicly.
The first question when I talk about this
book is everyone says, "You're a cancer doctor.
Why do you have the right to publish this
book and talk about it?"
To me, it comes from the old adage that in
order to understand peace, you have to go
to war.
Fighting cancer for the last 25 years has
brought, in my mind, a whole new way of approaching
health.
The team that I work with are two other individuals
who bring very unique ways of looking at health.
I've got Murray Gell-Mann.
Murray is probably the greatest living physicist.
Discovered the quark, string theory.
He won the Nobel Prize in 1969.
Now, he's working on modeling health with
our team.
And a guy named Danny Hillis, who built the
first supercomputer and discovered RAID storage
in the old days, and is again one of the great
engineers who is now working on modeling health
now.
What you'll see is the result of us thinking
about health or approaching it as a biologist,
a physicist, and an engineer.
I'll show you a new model, looking at health
as a complex emergent system as disease in
the body, how one can apply it, so it will
be prescriptive, and then how technology is
going to be, in my mind, what allows us and
brings us the hope to actually bring us change.
The first question is: what is health?
Is it your cholesterol?
Is it your weight?
Is it how you feel?
Is it how you sleep?
Is it how you look?
How do you define health?
Any engineer will tell you it's impossible
to optimize a system unless you develop parameters
on which to optimize.
So what is it?
Is it how long you live?
Is it what you look like?
On what parameter are we going to optimize
health?
We don't have a blood test for health.
If I asked you today, "Are you healthy?",
how do you respond?
That's one of the fundamental problems is
I don't know how to define health when I look
at it.
We can talk about all the corporate wellness
programs in the world, but corporate wellness
programs will optimize on lowering health
insurance costs.
Corporate illness programs are about delaying
illness till retirement.
But I want to figure out a way to optimize
health.
We'll talk about ways I think we could start
to do that, going forward.
Mark Twain, in his imminent wisdom, said,
"The only way to keep your health is to eat
what you don't want, drink what you don't
like, and do what you'd rather not."
[laughter] When I asked Steve, "Why didn't
you like the title What Is Health?"
He said, "If you put the word health in the
title, people think of chewing cardboard."
That's part of the problem, is that health
is something that we know we're not going
to like if you say what you have to do.
Things that are unhealthy are more appealing.
What I'll try to show you today is that that's
not really the case.
By definition, things in health don't have
to be unappealing.
Again, we go to what is that metric for health.
Well, in the United States, we spent over
a billion dollars last year in people over
the age of 50 getting growth hormone.
Why?
If I give you growth hormone at age 50, 60,
or 70, you're going to look better in a couple
of months.
You're going to be all buff.
Your friends are going to come and be all,
"Hey, what happened to you?
Did you get a haircut?
You look great."
You're going to feel better.
You're going to live, on average, 12 or 13
years less.
But you're going to look better.
And yet, our country, we do this all the time.
People go in, especially in my city, Los Angeles,
and they get shots of growth hormone to look
better.
They take, whether it be steroids, they get
Botox, they get all kinds of things to look
better.
But again, I want people to think about tomorrow
as well as today.
There's an amazing group of people in Ecuador
that was identified in a paper in Science
this last year, where they actually looked.
They have a mutation of the growth hormone
receptor.
These people don't get cancer and don't get
diabetes at all in their populations.
They have other problems, but what we also
know is that species that grow larger or members
of a species that grow larger have more health
problems.
And yet, we as a society push to making people
larger.
One of the chapters of the book is about football
players.
Football players are, in general, very large,
have a lot of inflammation, as we'll talk
about.
CNN did a story on this for the Super Bowl.
I can't tell you how many hate emails I got,
and letters.
"You're taking away American culture."
"You're screwing us."
I'm not against football, but I'm against
the concept of inflammation.
I'm against the concept of the bigger, the
better, as we'll talk about.
We need to start to identify what are the
metrics each of us individually are going
to look at, because obviously, we want to
live until our 90s.
The key is avoid disease.
I look at 2 to 3 people a week, and I say,
"I've got no more drugs to treat your cancer.
I've run out.
And unfortunately, the cancer's going to win."
I don't want to do that anymore.
The way to stop that is to avoid disease.
Most diseases can be delayed or avoided.
I don't know if you guys saw the paper last
week, but now we'll make Alzheimer's a disease
of the past over the next 5 to 7 years.
It's astonishing, but Alzheimer's will go
away.
If you look at it, a month ago, 15% of us
in the room will be affected by Alzheimer's.
As of the data last week, it's staggering.
There are two big advances.
The first is they took a couple of cells that
made this abnormal protein called tau, which
is what messes up the brain in Alzheimer's.
They put them in the brain of a mouse.
Then they sacrificed the mouse a couple weeks
later.
And what do you know: those tangles are all
over the brain.
So Alzheimer's isn't a disease of the brain,
it's a disease of a couple cells that then
spreads its proteins throughout the brain.
If you block that, you no longer will have
Alzheimer's.
We have a mouse model now that's accurate.
We can develop it.
Instead of testing in humans-- The problems
in testing in patients is you've got to do
it for ten years.
You're not going to know until-- ahh!-- ten
years later whether it worked or not.
So now we've got a model.
And then, get a load of this, they took a
drug for lymphoma that had been FDA approved
already, it's on the market, and they gave
it to these mice.
Well, if a mouse-- You drop a napkin in a
cage, they chew it up and make a little nest.
It's called nesting.
You give a mouse Alzheimer's, they just sit
in a corner and act like this and do nothing.
You give them this drug for lymphoma with
the Alzheimer's, two days later, they're making
a nest again.
You look in the brain of the animal, 60% of
these tangles are gone.
Again, this is a drug that's already FDA approved
and on the market.
So we're going to have a marked impact on
Alzheimer's and every disease we'll talk about
today.
The key is delaying them or preventing them
so you, I, our loved ones, can benefit from
those advances.
And again, we talked about that it's actually
going to lower costs if we do this right.
In the 1930s, J.B.S.
Haldane, who was the great thinker of the
time, said this amazing quote, because it
really is true today.
He was right.
He predicted it 90 years ago.
He said, "Bacteria and this germ theory is
going to screw up everything because we're
going to forget about the system.”
We're going to treat other diseases like cancer,
heart disease, and Alzheimer's like infectious
disease, and we're going to be wrong.
He was right.
Remember, infectious disease, you make the
diagnosis, you know the treatment.
It's easy.
That bacteria, that antibiotic, they work.
It doesn't care if you're short, round, tall,
fat, green, yellow, blue.
It will work because bacteria come from without.
The problem is, human disease comes from within.
Human disease, you make a diagnosis, most
of the time you don't know the treatment because
it's the interaction of that disease in your
body that's unique in each of us.
Very different from infectious disease.
Yet, over the last 90 years, we've been treating
almost all disease like infectious disease.
You have X, let me give you Y.
Most of the time, unfortunately, that doesn't
work.
This is one of the sad figures that's in the
book that I get a lot of comments about, which
is heart disease, stroke, down dramatically
in death rate over the last 50 years.
Cancer, not really a change.
Well, what caused this major decline?
Two things.
Smoking: we're smoking less.
And then statins: statins are class of drug
that were developed to lower LDL, the bad
cholesterol, and then they were given to patients.
They had a dramatic effect on heart disease
and stroke.
Turns out that their mechanism, how they work,
was different than lowering cholesterol, as
I will talk about.
It's because they're one of the great anti-inflammatory
drugs we have.
The root of diseases like heart disease and
cancer inflammation.
In fact, statins will reduce the incidence
of cancer beautifully if one takes them for
several years.
So, dramatic effect here, yet influenza, right:
we can give vaccines, we have antibiotics,
fantastic.
Cancer, not really a big impact.
So cancer, we've treated a reductionist way.
The amazing thing about cancer that people
don't get is-- Again, I was one of the heads
of the Cancer Genome Project, so I'm as guilty
as anybody else.
But if you look at breast cancer under a microscope,
a pathologist will look and say, "Hey, it's
breast cancer."
They don't care what the genetics are.
The body doesn't care what the genetics are.
Breast cancer looks like breast cancer.
Colon cancer looks like colon cancer.
Evolution is selecting out for phenotype,
what it looks like, not the underlying genetics.
There are 150 ways to get to be breast cancer,
yet they all look alike.
Yet our treatments, we keep trying to hit
those molecular abnormalities.
We forget the other part.
A clinical trial was done about 10 years ago
that people thought was crazy, that now is
the standard of care in the treatment of a
disease, breast cancer.
What we did was it took women after optimal
treatment.
Half got placebo, and half got a drug that
builds bone, a drug for osteoporosis.
Recurrence was reduced by 40% Why?
Breast cancer metastasizes to bone.
If you change the soil, the seed doesn't grow.
We just made the body inhospitable to breast
cancer.
And what do you know, it didn't come back
in those women.
A powerful statement, a powerful way to treat
disease.
Because to me, diseases like cancer, Alzheimer's,
heart disease, they are verbs, not nouns.
You're cancering.
You're heart diseasing.
I want to change you from that disease state
to a health state.
It's a different way of approaching disease
if you think about it.
The way I look at it is at a complex emergent
system, where you've got inputs.
Your input is your DNA.
Your input's what you eat.
It's your environment.
It's your work environment.
It's your friends.
Those are all your inputs.
Your output is how you feel.
That middle state function has been historically
hidden.
We haven't been able to look at it.
Historically, we give change in input and
we see how it affects the output, with all
those inputs.
But we've never been able to look in the middle.
Well, on the cover of the book, let me just
borrow this for one sec, we can all of a sudden
see the state function.
This is a picture of the human proteome.
It's a drop of blood going through a supercomputer,
I mean a superconducting magnet, where we
get a 50 to 60 gigabyte image of all the proteins
in the blood.
That's that state function.
For the first time, we can see.
We'll talk about that a little more in a minute.
But all of a sudden, you've got various state
functions that are equivalent classes of history.
They are patients with heart disease, patients
with cancer.
We can start to modulate them.
For the first time now with technology, we
can actually see them.
Well, the bad news is it is almost impossible
to understand complex emergent systems.
The good news is, you can control the systems
you can't understand.
If I asked my 11 year old boy, "How do you
stop a train?", he just says, "You pull the
brake."
He doesn't first say, "What's the weight of
the train?
What's the track made of?
What's the temperature?
What's the air speed?"
He just says, "Listen.
I've got to figure out a way to control it."
My field has spent the last 50 years trying
to understand diseases like cancer rather
than just working on ways to optimize and
control them.
The average cancer on diagnosis has how many
mutations?
130.
If I can pick one that I could target with
a drug, do you really think it's going to
make a major difference?
Remember, my field, cancer, we try to shrink
the disease by 50%.
That's called a win, and that's what we get
FDA approval on.
Well, 50% isn't even an order of magnitude
when you're talking hundreds of billions of
cells.
There's something missing here in what we're
doing.
There's something missing in how we're approaching
these.
1997, I was a trainee at Sloan-Kettering.
A kid, 25 year old kid, had germ cell tumor
of the brain, the lung, and the liver.
He went to the best hospitals in the country.
They told him, "Listen, chemotherapy is just
going to make you sick.
Why don't you go home to Texas and spend your
last couple months with your family?"
Instead, this kid went to Indianapolis.
He went there because some goofball doc, and
I say the word goofball affectionately, he
took two platinum electrodes and put it in
a gel and said, "Do cancerous cells like electricity
or not?"
Well, it turns out, they didn't really care
about the electricity.
But some of the platinum in those rods killed
some of the cells.
So they gave it-- This is the same thing in
my wedding band.
They give it intravenously to this kid in
Indianapolis.
A year and a half later, he won his first
of 7 Tours de France.
Why did platinum cure Lance Armstrong?
I have no freaking idea.
Yet you can find 50 explanations in the scientific
literature.
"Well, it affects the DNA adducts and here
and here."
Again, we don't really know how these drugs
work.
Most chemotherapy, I'll challenge you, I don't
think chemotherapy has any data that it actually
touches the cancer cell.
It works, believe me, but it probably changes
your system so the cancer doesn't want to
grow anymore.
We don't have data that it actually targets
and hits the dividing cancer cells.
Cancer cells are very similar to normal cells.
So again, when you think of this complex emergent
system, we have to look at different ways
of measuring the system, looking at perturbations,
when we look at disease.
Remember, I'm the same field that put out
ads like this.
I'm the same field that put out ads like this.
And this.
You can't forget the dentists.
I'm the same field, that 25, 30 years ago
said, "Take margarine, not butter."
We killed millions of people by telling them
to do that.
Over and over again, we make these declaratory
statements without any real data.
We make these observational findings.
There's an association of X with Y, and therefore,
we should avoid X.
One of the things I'll talk to you about in
a minute is vitamins.
Again, which gets people really upset, because
many people-- Vitamins have been a crutch
which they're leaning on for the last several
decades.
And I'm taking away that crutch.
They get really upset.
I spoke at the Commonwealth Club last night,
and I had protestors.
I've never had a protestor before.
It's true, I'm different than most people
in that the protestors were 85 years old.
It's a very different kind of protestor who
protests with what I have to say.
But you'll look at things like vitamin D,
as we'll talk about.
Right now, if you're over the age of 50, 60%
of people are taking vitamin D supplementation.
The government in Canada had to outlaw vitamin
D testing because it was 11% of their healthcare
budget two years ago.
Why are people testing for vitamin D?
Because there are associations.
People with lower vitamin D have a slightly
higher cancer rate and a slightly heart disease
rate.
Also, if you smoke, you have lower vitamin
D. If you're obese, you have lower vitamin
D. Nobody's saying if you give vitamin D,
you're going to stop smoking, but there's
that association, too.
We'll talk about some of the data, because
it really has been leading us astray in many
of the things we do.
One of the great examples is exercise.
Our exercise notion in our country is: you
do an hour of exercise at the gym or the DVD
you put in your machine and watch and do some
yoga for an hour, and then you sit at your
desk the rest of the day.
Well, if you start to look at the data, real
studies, and we'll talk about some of them,
as old as 60 years old.
The data shows that an hour of exercise a
day is awesome.
You sit the rest of the day, you negate it
all, and it causes harm.
In fact, that harm, if one does a quantitation
on incidence of heart disease, it's worse
than smoking, if you look at it.
So they key is moving.
The original study done is the coolest study.
It was published in 1953 in the British medical
journal Lancet.
Nobody paid attention to it.
It wasn't referenced for literally 40 or 50
years.
They did something with privacy rules, now
nobody can do.
This guy, Jeremiah Morris, went and looked
at the 26,000 workers in the British Transit
Authority.
He just looked at all their data.
He didn't care who they were.
He just looked at their data.
What he said is that there were two classes
of employees.
There were the bus drivers that sat 90% of
the day and drove the buses.
Then there were the ticket takers that walked
around and took the tickets on those double
decker buses.
Well, the heart disease deaths were 60% less
in the ticket takers compared to the bus drivers
even though they weighed the same, they ate
the same, they lived in the same neighborhoods.
They had everything the same.
The difference was one group sat and one group
walked.
Powerful argument.
He went further in that paper.
This is one of the coolest graphs in science.
It looks at death rate as associated with
profession.
What it showed is the worst professions were
hairdressers who stood in one place, or the
typists who sat in one place.
The best professions, believe it or not, were
the coal miners and the gardeners, because
they moved and they walked.
Today, Nike is launching a product that's
called Fuel, which is a band which you wear.
It looks at how much you move during the day.
It communicates via Bluetooth.
It creates these communities, because unfortunately
or fortunately, depending how you look at
it, we all need competition to do the right
thing.
It's going to create competition among friends,
among corporations, employees, to start to
move more during the day and quantitate it.
Moving equates to better health.
I wore one of those accelerometers and I realized
I was sitting most of the day.
I got one of those phones that made me look
like an air traffic controller.
Now, when I'm in my office, I'm walking, talking
on the phone.
I've reduced by half the amount of time I
sit.
Someone comes to meet you during the day,
say, "Let's go for a walk."
That's a sign of respect, rather than just
sitting in a conference room and talking.
I know what a difference in corporate culture,
but over time, will make an enormous difference
on health.
Obviously, I talk a lot on negative stuff,
and what we're doing wrong.
But obviously, we're doing things right.
If you look in the United States between 1900
and 2008, there's a dramatic increase in how
long we live.
True, much of that increase comes from reducing
infant mortality, because these data can be
somewhat misleading.
If infants live past the age of 5, the chances
are they're going to live till they're 60.
That obviously skews the results to the right.
Especially worldwide, now, we're starting
to eliminate much of infant mortality.
But at the same time, we are living longer.
So we are doing some things right.
The problem, the fundamental problem, is that
evolution selects out for who has good kids.
It doesn't select out for who lives until
their 90s.
We forget that sometimes.
In order to go to your 90s, you've got to
optimize a little, and tweak, because evolution
didn't take care of us.
There are things that can help you during
childbearing years that may hurt you later
on.
For example, if you skip your flu shot this
year, which I'm sure none of you did.
If you skip your flu shot, and you got the
flu, you will all survive.
I guarantee you.
You'd have five, six, seven days of feeling
poor, etcetera, and then you'd go back to
work and you'd be fine.
A decade from now, your risk of heart disease
and cancer are 10 and 12% elevated, because
those five to seven days of marked inflammation
will have its manifestation a decade from
now.
Our culture is all about what will affect
us today, not tomorrow.
We have to think more long term, as I'll show
you.
US mortality, and this is--.
Unfortunately the data is several years lagging,
always.
If you look at it, a quarter of deaths are
heart disease.
Men higher than women, so 40% of us will die
of heart disease, about 20% of them women,
will die of heart disease.
Cancer, stroke, infections.
Most of these things are delayable or preventable
by current technologies.
Yet most of the things we'll talk about we
ain't really doing.
I'm not sure why.
One of the technologies in full disclosure.
I'm a cofounder of Navigenics, one of the
DNA companies out there.
You guys are an investor.
Google was an original investor in Navigenics.
I did it because the government had been spending
close to a billion dollars a year looking
at gene associations with disease.
And yet, nobody was using the data or benefiting
from it.
So 1974, Monsanto's annual report, they set
150 million dollars to sequence one gene.
Two weeks ago on Nightline, Bill Weir, the
Nightline anchor, came to my office.
This was live on Nightline.
We sequenced his genes.
We showed he was higher risk of heart disease.
Based on that, we did a heart scan, live on
TV.
He's a 42 year old, fit guy.
Kids under the age of six.
Traveling all over the world.
He's now in-- Just did a report yesterday
on the Foxconn workers for Apple and all the
issues.
He's traveling all over.
We showed, live on TV, that in his heart artery,
the big artery, the LED going to his heart,
there's a big lesion there.
He would have had a heart attack in the next
one, two, or five years, but we identified
this live on TV using the preventive strategies.
It saved his life.
The next day, the American Heart Association,
in their beautiful wisdom, says, "Agus screwed
up.
He wasn't eligible for screening."
I'm like, "Are you guys serious?
Either your criteria are wrong, because he
was positive.
Something is missing in this picture here."
So then they said, "Well, you're right.
Maybe the criteria can be changed a little.
But technology's bad, and screening, and there
are problems with that."
I got, "Then you guys should be saying, 'Why
aren't we putting more research in technology
to do better screening?'
Just blanket saying, 'He shouldn't have been
screened because too many people will be screened',
that's the wrong thing.
So it really scares me in that regard.
Many of you have already done this, but this
is me.
These are my DNA results.
Did it overnight tell me exactly what was
going on.
No.
But it was somewhat of a religious moment
for me, because all of a sudden, I looked
and I knew more about me.
I realized I have a 42% chance of having a
heart attack.
I had a normal cholesterol.
Based on that, I went on a statin.
We'll talk about that data in a minute.
I'm on an aspirin.
I'm lean body mass.
I exercise.
I actually changed behaviors.
I eat better.
When I saw myself on a piece of paper.
We always view ourselves different than we
really are.
It changed me.
But it's not only your genes.
This is a chart where the black is the genes,
the white is environment.
Almost every disease, there's an environmental
part that we can control, and there's a genetic
part that we can blame our parents for.
Although we like to blame our parents for
everything, none of these diseases are deterministic.
They don't just happen.
We can prevent them.
Whether it be by behavior, changing environment,
or actually drugs, all of them can help.
When we talk about drugs, and we'll talk more
about statins, but I get vilified saying I'm
a shill for the pharmaceutical company.
"Agus is out there pushing drugs.
He works for them.
He doesn't want to push the natural things
because then he'll be out of business in treating
disease."
The drugs I push-- You know how much a statin
costs?
Without health insurance, you can go to Wal-Mart
and get a 90 day supply for $9.
These are generics.
These are available.
These will radically change healthcare when
we start to look at the data.
Aspirin.
An aspirin a day, $3 a year to take baby aspirin,
81 mg a year.
If you start to look at the data, after five
years of aspirin, death due to GI cancer down
54%.
One case of colon cancer to a company like
Google costs $247,000.
Again, if you can reduce that by half by saying,
"Take an aspirin", I don't get why people
aren't doing it more.
After 20 years, death.
Death is a bad side effect.
Death due to prostate cancer down 10%.
Lung cancer, 30%.
Colo-rectal cancer, 40, esophageal cancer,
60%.
You start to look at this data.
You start to say-- Listen, I'm not saying
anybody should take a pill.
But I'm saying that conversation with a physician
needs to happen.
You need to say, because there are reasons
why you shouldn't be on it.
But you need to have to conversation and say,
"Listen, I understand there's data.
This may benefit me.
What are the downsides?
Talk about me as an individual, given my family
history, given my genetics, given my risk
factors.
I want to know why I'm not on something like
this."
If you're a company and you say to your employees,
"Listen, you can do whatever you want.
But if you have that discussion with your
doctor, I'm going to give you a discount on
your health insurance, because it's going
to benefit us."
Michael Dell was a hero to me in that he said,
"Listen, I have 105,000 employees at Dell.
They're welcome to smoke.
But if they smoke, they're going to have a
different health insurance cost than the non-smokers.
Because why should smokers be subsidized by
the non-smokers?"
That data are profound.
We need to push and change.
Obviously, it's aggressive.
People would get upset.
But we're the number one spender in healthcare
in the world, and our results are dismal.
16 1/2% of GDP and growing every year.
Unless we start to enact things and change
and prevent, it ain't going to get smaller.
You start to look at drugs like statins.
Again, these are prescription drugs now, although
about 6 months ago, they were filed to go
over-the-counter.
They're generic.
Again, they are inexpensive, costing about
$36 for an entire year of treatment.
You start to look at the data.
The Jupiter study, which was really a pivotal
study because it took people who had normal
cholesterol.
A normal cholesterol.
Not a high cholesterol, a normal cholesterol.
They put them on a pill a day.
What it did was it delayed heart attack and
stroke by over a decade.
Many cancers reduced their incidence by double
digit percentages.
Yes, a percent of people or less will have
some side effects.
It's 100% reversible.
If you have it, you stop.
But again, if we can have this dramatic effect
on disease, why aren't we using it more?
The cost is so low.
Again, I'm not getting why we're not doing
it.
And yet, we do the other side, which is we
take pills.
Ends up costing more than these pills I just
talked about.
39,000 women tracked over 19 years.
You can criticize all the study all you want,
but they looked at women who took vitamins.
Vitamin B6, folic acid, and copper, and iron
versus women who didn't.
Actually, the women who took the vitamins
were healthier baseline.
They were skinnier.
They had less diabetes.
They looked at them and said, "What's the
difference in the outcome?
Well, a 15% higher death rate in the women
who took the supplements."
15% higher death rate in the women who took
the supplements.
I look at that and I say, "Whew.
By the year 2004, 65% of women in this country
were taking supplements."
I said, "There's got to be some data behind
it, or why would all these women be doing
it?
Why would it be a multi, multibillion dollar
industry if there weren't some benefit there
to it?"
Then I look on the internet, and this is just
in the last couple months.
These are all the headlines about vitamin
D. According to this, it can cure every disease
known to mankind.
I mean, that's great.
Then I look and said, "There's got to be data
here.
There's got to be data why this happens."
In the United States, now, over 75% of us
are quote low in vitamin D. There's data that
there's an epidemic of low vitamin D over
the last decade.
As we spend more time indoors, wear sunscreen,
vitamin D levels are coming down.
Yet, hip fracture rates are also down over
that same period.
So it starts to make you wonder why is that
really the case?
What is normal?
Who defines what a normal value is?
When I was born, I didn't come with an ingredient
manual that says, "Your normal value of vitamin
D should be X."
Because remember, vitamin D is a network,
not an individual node.
There's vitamin D, there's the receptor, and
then there are six signaling molecules.
All we're measuring is one part of a network.
So if you've low vitamin D, it probably means
you've got a high binding receptor.
Or you've got an elevated number of receptors.
Or one of the signaling molecules is a little
bit higher than somebody else.
Yet, we look at this and we all start saying,
"Hey, we're low in vitamin D.
We've got to correct that."
But part of it comes from the notion that
if you go to your doctor and he or she draws
arbitrary lab values, because unfortunately
most of them are somewhat arbitrary, and they
say, "Come back in a year", you say, "Listen.
I shouldn't have gone.
There was no value from going to my doctor.
That wellness visit.
He didn't tell me to do anything.
Or she didn't say anything different."
They say, "Vitamin D's low.
Take vitamin D." You perceive value.
That physician perceives they gave you value.
That perception is key.
About 2 and 1/2 years ago, the World Health
Organization came out with a blanket statement
saying, "Cell phones may cause brain cancer."
There was a panic around the world.
If you start to look at what is the root data
they went on, what they did was they looked
at 26,000 people with brain cancers.
They asked the brain cancer patient and the
spouse, "How much did you use the cell phone?"
When they answered, it was almost 2 and 1/2
times more in the brain cancer patient than
the spouse.
So spouses are a good control.
Pretty similar genetics, same environment,
eat the same, live the same.
And 2 and 1/2 [inaudible] more cell phone
usage.
Well, clearly, there may be an association.
A clever group went and said, "Let's audit
the cell phone records, because we can do
that."
They went back and they were exactly the same,
because human perception is we blame something.
"I have brain cancer, I must have done something
wrong.
Well, the cell phone, that's why.
I talk on the cell phone."
So they perceive they did it differently.
You went to breast cancer patients, 2000 breast
cancer patients, and you say, "What was your
diet before and after you were diagnosed with
breast cancer?"
Uniformly, the women said, "My diet was horrible.
I have breast cancer.
I saw the light.
Now I'm healthy."
When they went back and audited what they
ate, it was exactly the same.
So again, human nature is we've got to blame
something.
There's something-- When something bad happens,
something's wrong.
"Something happens to my child, it must be
that vaccine they got, because there's got
to be a reason for it."
Or "If I have this problem, it's got to be
because of something I did or something in
the environment", etcetera.
We all want to blame something.
But let's go back and look at the data of
vitamin D. They took women 70 years and older,
over 2000 of them, and they gave them a very
high dose of vitamin D. That raised their
serum vitamin D level for a year.
26% higher fracture rate.
Not lower.
Higher fracture rate.
So all of a sudden, women are taking vitamin
D to increase their bone density and prevent
fractures.
And yet, this is a very well respected journal
with a couple thousand patients.
So an increase in bone fracture rate.
Hmm.
Remember, the body's homeostatic.
You take a bolus of something, you down-regulate
receptors and you screw up the signaling.
What's the only reason we tan?
To block vitamin D absorption.
Right there, evolution has a very difficult
way, it requires a lot of energy, that we've
evolved so we don't have too much vitamin
D. Yet we take these big boluses of pills
all the time.
Then, well, "maybe the dose was too high."
So they did a study in women where they took
women-- oh!-- who, in the nurses' health studies.
Again, over 20,000 women were looked at.
They gave them vitamin D and calcium.
The regular vitamin D and calcium that most
people take.
The Os-Cal D or whatever brand it is.
In that study, there was no effect on bone
fracture by taking calcium and vitamin D.
There were side effects that caused kidney
stones, it affected gastric upset, all of
those things.
Yet no benefit.
Most women, most women over the age of 60,
take calcium and vitamin D.
The first question to ask your doctor if they
say, "You should be on calcium and vitamin
D" is "Why?"
Osteoporosis, we know, is a genetic disorder.
Taking calcium and vitamin D doesn't make
it better.
Yet we do it.
Again, something a little screwy there, in
my mind.
And then this study.
This was a $240 million study, almost a quarter
billion dollars stamped by the US government.
Vitamin E.
We know vitamin E's a great antioxidant.
Everybody's taking it to prevent prostate
cancer.
Let's see how much it prevents prostate cancer.
So they gave men 400 units.
This is the same amount in a multivitamin.
They gave them that.
After three years, they halted the study.
A quarter billion dollar study.
Why?
Because there was a 17% higher incidence of
prostate cancer in the men who took vitamin
E. That lasted for three, four years after
stopping the vitamin.
A 17% increase in the most common non skin
cancer in men.
First of all, the impact on the individual
is staggering.
The impact on society, on companies, on our
health insurance, is staggering because we're
taking this.
Again, what am I missing here?
We're talking a $20 to 30 billion impact on
healthcare by this excess in men diagnosed
with prostate cancer.
Then you look.
The government said, "Listen.
Maybe there are some studies that we're missing
here."
So they looked at 63 studies with more than
500 people in a randomized fashion with multivitamins
and heart disease and cancer.
None of them showed a benefit.
Zero showed a benefit.
I've just showed you a number of studies with
clear negatives.
And yet, none has yet shown a benefit.
In 2004, they looked and they said, "People
who smoked, or former smokers, we've got to
give them high dose antioxidants to prevent
lung cancer, because they're dying like in
droves of lung cancer."
28% higher lung cancer when they took these
supplements.
17% higher death rate when they took these
Again, pills, I'm not sure they actually have
benefits.
Clearly, they're causing harm.
The other side of the equation is looking
at how technology's going to fit in.
Because clearly, there probably are some people
that benefit from taking pills.
If you're pregnant, you need to take prenatal
vitamins.
There's certain eye conditions were vitamins
have been shown to help.
Maybe some people with their diet need it.
But we need technology to start to say who
needs what, because blanket statements like
I'm making probably aren't the best thing
going forward.
In 1976, if you thought you were pregnant,
or your spouse thought she was pregnant, you
took a tube of blood, you went to a hospital
because it couldn't be done anywhere but a
hospital.
Every hospital in the country had a rabbit
floor.
We took that blood, and we injected it into
a poor rabbit.
Five days later, we sacrificed the rabbit
and we looked at the rabbits ovaries.
If they were enlarged, you were pregnant.
That was the state of the art in 1976.
Well, 1977, the first proteomic test was approved
by the FDA.
It was a $10 urine-based test for pregnancy.
Rabbits over the world rejoiced.
[laughter] All of a sudden, we had a binary
outcome.
Yes/no whether you're pregnant or not.
It radically changed reproductive health,
women's health, child mortality because we
can actually give prenatal vitamins, we can
take care of women because we knew they were
pregnant.
Changed everything.
We need more technologies like this.
We now have the capacity with newer technology,
to actually bring them in.
This is the proteomics.
This is the cover on the book.
This is that 20,000 foot view of the state
of the system, where, instead of--.
In our country, we do a colonoscopy at age
50, because that's where the risk rewards
come together, and that's what's cost effective.
I love that word.
It's cost effective to do.
Well, what do you say to the 4000 people in
the United States last year who died of colon
cancer under the age of 40?
"You weren't cost effective?"
What do you say to the fact that only 17%
of people who should have colonoscopies do,
at age 50?
What if we had a blood test to say who had
a colonic polyp?
First of all, we would do it in the right
people.
We'd have almost 100% compliance.
And the other is, we have a quality metric.
Did that doc get the polyp our or not?
Because right now, there is no quality metric.
That's what technology can do, is start to
personalize things.
We're not far away from that.
There's a newer technology coming out that's
pretty wild.
Turns out, you and I have 10 fold more bacteria
in us than we do cells in our body.
If someone is in China, you look at the incidence
of prostate cancer and breast cancer, it's
1/10 what ours is.
After they move to the United States, after
a decade, it starts to approach ours.
"Well, then it's the Burger King and the McDonald's."
Turns out, that's not the case.
It's the bacteria in the water.
It's our microbiome.
They get populated with our bacteria.
Well, those bacteria, they control how you
metabolize your food.
They control your hormone levels.
For the first time ever this year, we've learned
to quantitate them and actually look at what
type are populating what individual.
I guarantee you, over the next several years,
we're going to start to modulate them to reduce
risk for disease, which will be powerful.
I'm a believer in prevention.
I look at the data.
There are little things one can do that can
radically affect health.
In the Framingham heart study, one of the
most protective effects wasn't what you ate,
it wasn't your weight.
It was actually owning a dog.
We look at the data.
"A dog?
Well, it relaxes you."
Well, it's not that it relaxes you.
It puts you on a regular schedule.
If you start to look at the data on regularity,
it is profound for health.
If you have your lunch today at noon, and
then tomorrow at 2:00, for two hours, stress
hormones go up.
When stress hormones go up, the body goes
in a protective mode.
It says, "Hey, listen.
There might be a lion coming.
I've got to really save energy.
I've got to shut down."
So you get about a 25-30% decrease in cognition.
You get about a 36% decrease in exercise performance.
You actually gain weight because you lower
metabolism dramatically to try to save energy.
So if you eat on a regular schedule, sleep
on a regular schedule, dramatic effect on
health.
It's the person who randomly goes by places
like this and grabs and apple that hurt themselves.
If you have an apple every day at 3:00, greatest
thing in the world.
Regularity is key.
Almost as important as what you eat.
Very powerful, costs nothing, and can have
a dramatic effect on health.
So I'm happy to stop here, answer questions.
I know we've went through a lot and went all
over the place.
But all the data is in the book.
We're proud of it.
It's aggressive.
I'd love to get comments back from you.
Email me.
Tell me what you think.
But again, questions, we're happy to talk.
I appreciate it.
[applause]
>>Agus: Yes.
>>male #1: : Thanks for coming to talk.
>>Agus: Thank you.
>>male #1: I guess I'm curious about what
you would say about the way people interact
with their doctors.
At the start of your talk, you mentioned that
in China, they're going to implement some
of the stuff as law.
In the United States, it's going to be much
more decentralized and debated.
I can go to a doctor who graduated medical
school 20 years ago or 40 years ago or 5 years
ago, and they're probably have very different
reactions.
But you advised us to not even take an aspirin
a day without going to that.
>>Agus: I want that discussion to happen,
you're right.
One of the things we put early in the book.
You can download it.
It's a four page questionnaire I want you
to fill out before you go to your doctor.
There's this old adage, and obviously you
here know well which is "Enough data, error
goes away."
When you go to your doctor, they check your
blood pressure at 1:00.
Well, who ever checks it in the morning when
you get up?
At night when you go to bed?
When you're pissed off after a phone call?
I want a lot of data.
I want you to look at your own metrics.
You go on with all your data.
But if your doctor's not going to listen,
go to a different doctor.
It's a free market system.
The only way we're going to change it is from
the ground up.
I wrote this book so each of us can be in
charge and go in with that data.
Go in and say, "Listen.
The studies show this.
I fit that study.
What do you think?" and start to have a real
discussion.
You can go in with everything written down
in this questionnaire before you go in, so
that five minutes, if you're lucky, ten minutes
with your doctor, you can actually use it
correctly.
But you're right.
We have to change the doctors.
We are incentivized, and I'm as guilty as
anybody else, for treatment.
We're not incentivized for prevention.
We need to change that in our country.
The average time on a health plan is 4 1/2
years.
Your health plan doesn't care about preventing
your heart disease.
It's not going to happen for 10 years, and
you'll be on somebody else's plan.
We have to change that way of thinking, and
we're going to do it from the ground up.
>>male #1: Thank you.
>>male #2: [clears throat] One of the [clears
throat] fascinating and compelling points
I think you made was that we should look at
the proteome and look for ways to modify your
biochemistry to conform to that template.
>>Agus: Yes.
>>male #2: I assume that's a good starting
point.
But do think that there's going to be a need
to look at it as a dynamic system where the
template will adapt over age or time or environmental
conditions?
How do we figure out the right template for
a person?
>>Agus: With enough data.
The thing is, I'd love there--.
One day, when you go to your doctor, he pricks
your finger.
It goes into some technology that profiles
it.
You're populating the data set as well as
getting something back from it.
Just akin to my search on Google is better
today than it was yesterday, I want medicine
to improve on a daily basis.
And we're not.
We don't have common data elements.
It's shocking.
You call it a broken leg, I call it a fractured
leg.
Nobody's standardized data elements and nomenclature
in my field yet.
It is absolutely from the 1920s.
We need to change that.
The technology is here.
We've got to use it right.
Building the standards to allow it to actually
grow.
Yeah.
>>male #3: I recently saw a documentary about
Stanislaw Burzynski.
It seemed like a really interesting documentary.
I looked online to get more information, and
it seemed like the government and the entire
medical community thought this guy was a quack.
>>Agus: So you really think there's a conspiracy?
This is a guy in Texas who now has moved to
Mexico who has a drug that he developed called
antineoplaston.
He charges cash, $60,000, to give it to you.
He argues, there's a conspiracy-- What he
does is he went to all the cancer meetings,
stands up in the audience.
He goes to some random meetings and he stands
up and starts talking about it.
Everyone's like, "Sit down, be quiet”, because
it's interrupting whoever's talking about
something else.
He films it and shows these videos.
"The community is against me."
They're against him because he's interrupting
somebody else speaking.
There have been four randomized studies done
with this, causing increased death, shorter
life span, than not.
He's out there saying, "There's a conspiracy.
The government and doctors want to hide it
because we're going to take away their business
if I cure all disease."
>>male #3: : I feel like--
>>Agus: What am I missing here?
>>male #3: : --he doesn't seem trustworthy,
which is why I didn't totally--
>>Agus: : There were four randomized trials.
It didn't work.
Made people live shorter.
>>male #3: I was just more curious about--
I'm more interested in experimentation because
bodies are different.
What might work for you might not work for
me and vice versa.
I'm wondering if you feel like there's something
within the system that just doesn't allow
as much experimentation as there could be.
>>Agus: That's a great point.
By definition, with advanced cancer, you want
to be on a clinical trial because standard
therapy doesn't work.
You want to experiment and do new things.
We are very much risk averse in our world.
The capital markets have been closed to biotechnology
for the last 15 years.
There are very few of any biotech companies.
Pharmaceutical companies are bonds.
They want to return 5% a year.
They're not taking risk and doing their clinical
trials.
One of the arguments in the book is I think
we have enough drugs out there.
We've just got to learn how to use them, and
we're not.
So I agree with you.
We need to take more experiments.
Cancer patients especially are willing to
take any risk in the world because they've
got no choice.
And yet, most of the time we don't do that.
It's public that I was one of Steve Jobs'
doctors.
He puts in his book how we sequenced his genome.
We didn't sequenced his genome.
We sequenced a couple of genes.
We looked at it, and everything we did was
part of clinical trials.
He went on drugs, and so did everybody else
there.
I'm a believer in trials.
I'm a believer in doing randomized clinical
trials, or clinical trials that are single
armed to see if these drugs work.
And many of them do.
I chair one of the brain cancer foundations.
About seven or eight years ago, I got a call
from a doctor in Galveston, Texas, who said,
"I give this drug called Avastin, a Genentech
drug, to a patient with glioblastoma, and
it worked."
I go, "There's no way.
It's too big to even get across the blood-brain
barrier."
This story's in the book.
She said, "Well, here are the scans.
They look real."
So we did a trial on people who failed chemo.
They have weeks to live.
And at six months, nobody progressed.
This drug that didn't even cross the blood-brain
barrier worked because it bound a protein
and lowered the pressure of the cancer.
When you lower the pressure, the cancer stops
growing.
A year later, it's FDA approved and standard
treatment for brain cancer.
So we need to keep our eyes open and learn
from every experience.
Be they with somebody who's a little questionable
or not.
But right now, all we do is we have to report
the negatives to the FDA, the side effects
to the FDA.
I have a good response, a cure, I never have
to report it.
Nobody knows about it.
It's hidden.
We need to change that.
We need to get data out there.
We need to talk about our experiences and
learn from them, because we're not now.
Yeah.
>>male #4: I really like a lot of the examples
you're giving about the different kinds--
sorry-- kinds of inflammation that can occur
from sitting or obviously, not eating at the
same time every day.
What I'm really curious about: is there some
kind of centralized source where you know
the risk factors of various types of inflammation?
Because I think this is missing out there.
>>Agus: You're 100% right.
We have a poor man's metric now, which is
called high sensitivity c-reactive protein.
But we need to get better metrics for measuring
different kinds of inflammation, optimizing
whether it be the shoes you wear.
Your feet hurt at the end of the day, that's
inflammation.
I want to optimize.
I want to have a marker to say there's less
inflammation or more.
This is where we need to put the research
focus, where technology needs to go.
And it's not right now.
But you're right.
>>male #4: For example, relative to other
factors, not eating at the same time every
day--.
It's great that it yields an insight.
I guess there's other types of inflammation
that we're unaware of, but that inflammation
in particular, how does that--
>>Agus: That's not inflammation as much as
stress hormones.
Eating at the same time.
But yeah, we can't quantitate that for an
individual.
We can only quantitate that for the collective
group.
What you're getting at is that we want to
start to do it for your individual, and say,
"For you, it's better to do X, Y, or Z."
That's what I hope technology will be able
to yield.
Right now, the only mature technology we have
is genetics.
The others are immature.
But genetics, I mean, it's akin to standing
outside two Chinese restaurants and looking
at the ingredient list.
They're exactly the same.
You taste the food, one could be awesome,
one could be horrible.
Genetics is your ingredient list.
What's going on in that moment in time, that's--
There may be the metabolomics or the microbiomics
or the proteomics.
That's the next generation.
>>male #5: You mentioned about not taking
the flu shot.
That actually surprised me.
What you're saying is, if you get flu, that
has negative consequences later, 10 years
down the road.
Which is opposed to what you hear.
"You're not getting sick enough."
Generally, we basically have very good, compared
to you live in other countries where you get
sick more often.
Generally, your body has more immune built
up.
Essentially, it doesn't have auto-- you have
less autoimmune diseases because your body's
not fighting any diseases.
>>Agus: I guess I'm missing the point.
>>male #6: [inaudible] You're better off having
been exposed to--
>>Agus: Well, you are being exposed.
A vaccines exposes you, but it's less inflammation.
>>male #5: But the inflammation part, does
it-- Essentially, you're saying it lasts longer.
Can you elaborate more on if you became sick
now.
What are the downsides to that?
>>Agus: I think of it very simply.
If I give you a vaccine, you're going to make
a-- your arm hurts.
You're making an inflammatory response.
You're making antibodies against whatever
pathogen is in there.
Again, if you're lucky and it was that flu
strain, you're not going to get sick that
year.
If it's a different flu strain, your flu is
going to be less because you have cross-reactive
antibodies.
But you get the flu, it's a staggering inflammatory
storm.
You feel it.
You can barely move for days.
That inflammatory storm, your body shuts down
things like DNA repair and others to shunt
its energy to fight off that viral infection.
And bad things can happen down the road.
Yes.
I think it's a good thing to be exposed to--.
As a child we're exposed to multiple different
pathogens.
We develop new responses over time.
But vaccines are good.
Vaccines expose you to these in an environment
where you don't get as much of this profound
inflammation.
>>male #5: But isn't it like, you'll need
a vaccine at the age when you are basically
fit?
Not such a good thing.
I can understand why very early, you are--
>>Agus: No.
Again, the immune response, the small immune
response you make to a vaccine compared to
seven days of having an influenza, it's a
dramatic effect.
At least, the data show that.
>>male #5: You mentioned the rabbit study.
Didn't the rabbit die when you actually inject
with human blood?
>>Agus: : No.
It was plasma.
It wasn't blood cells.
Just the plasma.
Yes.
The rabbit died when you cut off his [laughter]
or her head.
Yes.
>>male #7: I saw you on the Daily Show, so
my question might be in the book.
But a lot of your presentation was very much
a blanket against vitamins.
Vitamins or external supplements, in that
nature.
In any age group or areas, do you have exceptions
for that, or is that your general philosophy?
>>Agus: Sure.
I mean, pregnant women I think should be on
vitamins.
We know that it helps for prenatal health.
Again, I'm not blanket against vitamins.
It's more as an example.
I want you to question everything you put
in your body.
Say, "Why am I doing this?
Is there data that I should be taking this
pill?"
I pray that one vitamin works.
I'm not against them.
I just pray they work.
Everybody in the world juices now.
Once you put a vegetable or fruit into a blender,
it's all degraded.
Within hundredths of a millisecond.
James Lind, captain of the British Royal Navy,
amazing guy.
He won the Battle of Trafalgar, he beat the
French, because he had limes on his ship.
His troops didn't get scurvy, and the French
did.
Like any good entrepreneur, at the end, he
said, "I happened to sell the extra limes."
He sold the lime juice.
It didn't work.
Didn't cure scurvy.
Why?
As soon as you squeeze that lime, everything's
degraded.
I just want you to ask the question.
Everything you do.
"Why am I doing it for me?"
>>male #7: You talked very positively about
statins.
Is that at a certain age group, or--
>>Agus: If you look at the data, people with
average risk factors, they start around 40
showing a benefit.
People with high risk factors, if they start
at 20, there's more of a benefit.
It really depends on-- If everyone in your
family had heart attacks in their 40s, you
want to start earlier.
If you've got no history of heart disease
or cancer in your family, maybe you don't
want to do it at all.
So I really want that discussion to happen
with your doctor, based on you.
But I think the discussions should happen
now, for all of us, in our 20s or 30s or 40s.
Keep having it.
[applause]